hey good morning morning everyone and
thank you Mike for that introduction
it's a pleasure to be here and have the
opportunity of this presentation and
then this conversation with all of you
so thanks Mike thanks this for the
opportunity and greetings and welcome to
all the few colleagues from Ethiopia
Ghana Liberia Mexico Rwanda and
Singapore and thank you for coming so I
was asked to speak somehow broadly about
global health leadership and I'll try
and do so from the perspective that
somehow Mike indicated of being a
physician a scientist having been what
people call a global health diplomat as
an ambassador and then for the last two
years as executive director of the
Global Fund to fight AIDS TB and malaria
and as you know since it was established
back in 2002 that is only seven years 67
years ago the Global Fund has become the
primary multilateral Thunder in the
fight against these three diseases that
still kill over four million people in
the developing world each year so there
are many ways I could speak about
leadership and many sort of qualities I
would see for leaders I've been thinking
about it as I was preparing for this
talk and some of the key words that came
to my mind where courage commitment
accountability ability to express a
vision that inspires people but also
making decisions
and dealing confidently where there are
consequences empathy inclusiveness
admitting and learning from lessons
capacity to listen and perhaps above all
and particularly in hard times such as
these as we go through the financial and
economic crisis I think the capacity to
remain hopeful even if give in difficult
times because when you talk about global
health and public health you talk about
bringing hope to people leadership of
course takes place in many places in
governments in institutions in business
in households and of course in
universities I come myself from academia
I have been teaching at the University
in Paris until like two years ago and i
really think that whatever the domestic
or political environment universities
since maybe the 13th century you know
have always offered creative leadership
for their countries and so I I do
welcome very much the initiative of this
program and my best wishes to to this
new program you're just launching so I
can't sort of help cover all of these
themes in in 45 minutes or whatever the
time here so I thought that would focus
on three areas first I'd like to be with
some give some personal reflections on
how I came to be where I am today and
what it is that i should have somehow
the audacity of speaking to you about
leadership and and I'd like to touch on
some lessons in leadership that that
came to me you know in between the time
when I started as a young
clinical immunologist in the first years
of the AIDS epidemic 22 now secondly I'd
like to speak about the AIDS epidemic
and about about the the leadership of
the epidemic and because that epidemic
not only has led us to where we are
today in global health but in fact has
profoundly impacted on the development
agenda and has really helped put health
global health at the forefront of the
development agenda and third maybe I'll
like to take a few minutes to speak
about the challenges I see the key
challenges I see for global health and
therefore to the health leaders that
that you are indifferent in your
different roles in different places
where you work to make sure that the
health health maintains its place in
difficult times as I was saying as a
leader in the development field and as a
leader in human and neighbor so let me
go back a few years of course you know
my own story is is not necessarily a
pattern for theatre shipped that I would
recommend to to others but as I think
about it I sort of wrote down four key
turning points in my career as a
physician and as a scientist to
highlight some of the lessons and then
that I believe has served me
subsequently in indifferent leadership
roles I actually first started
University as a student in Latin and
philosophy at the Sorbonne in Paris and
then I I sort of agitated and I
hesitated between going into medicine or
into political science actually I was
sort of pairing with with a student the
got close friend of mine who went into
political science and actually ended up
as you know the vice chair of the French
parliament now but I went into medicine
I went into medicine because obviously I
was persuaded that that was the best way
to serve people and and to contribute to
society and remembered and that was in
the in the mid-70s and this was a time
when immunology which is the area where
I specialize was was a sort of booming
specialty but it was there these were
booming areas for medicine the first
transplants heart surgery you know
nothing seemed impossible to to medicine
somehow there was a profound conviction
that science and medicine technology
will be able to solve all the problems
we we were facing so I did masters and
thesis in in parallel with my medical
studies and then I I completed some
postdocs very different postdocs one in
England at st. Mary's Hospital
Paddington in London where I I really
learned about you know being curious
raising questions the way the British
can do most of the conversations about
what an antibody monaco is you know took
place at the pub and but that was not
the place
to really learn how you actually do
signs how you ask the questions how you
learn about the methods how you learn
about reasoning putting forward the
hypotheses a deductive reasoning and in
those days I'm saying in those days
because I think now Europe has more than
caught up with it but in those days
these are the things you really needed
to come to the u.s. to learn and so I I
did spend close to four years actually
here I mean here in the other university
let's say in Cambridge Massachusetts so
so that that period as a as a as a young
academic you know has taught me lots of
things how to generate the question how
to design a a protocol how to collect
and analyze data and that I'd like to
say is the first lesson learning about
how to gather and use evidence because
evidence is the most powerful bass the
most powerful tool for action it's the
most powerful tool for advocacy is the
most powerful tool for leadership
evidence and actually my mentor at at
Harvard professor k Frank Boston that
time a renowned immunologist used to say
Michelle first get the data and then
write the editorials and this is and
this is something i will i will remember
now the second the second turning point
occurred when i actually returned to
paris i worked as a physician and a
researcher in the area of immunologic
mediated renal diseases that was a quite
a booming area of medicine renal disease
and and maybe also hematology were the
two areas where immunology he was
bringing a lot of about pathogenesis
mechanisms involved and and hope in the
future of innovative therapeutic
approaches and this was just about the
time when aids was being identified as
as a new disease so that period came
first initially as as a fascinating you
know ever either somehow thrilling time
to two young human ologist for those of
you who know a bit about immunology and
this was the time when we were actually
this was a time in Yale where when the
Charles Jan way was doing some of his
pioneer work but this is a this is a
extraordinary time of accumulation of
knowledge and knowledge that was
bringing hope for for very innovative
approaches to to diseases and what
happened with AIDS of course is that
this first these first months and these
first years of fascination some how
rapidly turned to a quite different mood
and a mood of despair the the first
tests for HIV became available in 1984
and testing blood donors for for HIV big
you know became or what was passed as a
law in in July in 1985 in in in my
country I was at that time working in in
the university hospital called obatala
bosa bosa is
to be the surgeon of Napoleon and that
happened to be the largest hospital for
cardiac surgery in France where the
first heart transplant was performed and
therefore that hospital had the largest
blood bank in in in in Paris and because
of that it had also the largest absolute
number of people detected as at that
time it was called la v+ serum in
addition to what that blood bank was
collecting blood from the very center of
Paris it was a fairly central facility
so for all of these reasons many many
people happen to be detected as positive
for for that virus that was identified
now 83 as you know and for which we we
really didn't know what the pattern of
the disease would be and what we should
tell to patients we were in those days
very much in a sort of hepatitis model
thinking that perhaps some of the
patients would do well for many years
whereas some others would will evolve
but then you know very soon in so that's
the second half of the 80s we could see
what what the devastation of AIDS is
what it was at that time and so the
second lesson is that you know where
when comparing with with learning about
the power of medicine and and technology
and the power of scientific evidence you
know I learned a second lesson and and
that lesson was about humility and about
the limits of of medicine and and these
were extremely frustrating years not
only frustrating
from a human perspective you know facing
the the suffering the isolation of the
patients but to bring it back to my
first lesson somehow these were very
frustrating times for a scientist and
for for many of us because for a
physician or for a scientist I think
there's nothing more frustrating than
not understanding because you can
because not understanding means not
helping and so I went through those
years the second half of the 80s as an
aids physician with more and more
patience with people dying in the world
every day every day in the total you
know years of total frustration death
and despair these were also the years
where you know trained as as a as I said
as an immunologist or a Reno physician I
was used to medicine being a sort of you
know being around reasoning being around
the deductive process I don't know
whether some of you have been doing Reno
medicine or hematology but three it's
really reading you know the results of
blood tests your intestine and reasoning
from that it's not a an area of Medicine
where you actually get physically in in
contact with with the wounds somehow of
people and aids that is the the
prototype of immune deficiencies of
course changed all of that because
patients in those days particularly were
coming with advanced disease and with
all of the symptoms you know kaposi's
sarcoma mycosis in the mouth
pneumocystis pneumonia
Megan virus disease in the eyes dementia
and so on and as if that was not you
know enough AIDS was also progressively
more and more coming as a a social
distress with drug use marginalization
discrimination homophobia and
association with poverty and and as a
result you know I think aids taught me
what I would call the third lesson here
that I'd like to leave with you which is
to focus on on the whole person and not
just on on the manifestations of disease
or on disease remember the definition
that the World Health Organization is
giving of of health which is so much
broader than just physical self health
it's about our physical mental and
social health and so it taught me and
they taught thousands of physicians
around the world a fundamentally
different paradigm about the
relationship between the doctor and the
patient these wear these were years
where where the power of the doctor what
the philosopher Michel Foucault called
the asymmetric relationship between the
one who actually detains the power
because he detains the knowledge and and
the one who confronts with with the
power the patient that relation was
completely was completely changed I
actually recently as I was speaking at
the harm International harm reduction
conference in Bangkok and I I spoke
about a patient whom I remember and who
I think was it either I'll come back to
that to me patients are lead
um he was called mr. and he was infected
through drug use and sharing needles he
lost his brother to AIDS he lost his
sister to AIDS he died of aids in the
early 90s and in the very first days of
of the epidemic I think in the you know
somewhere and in the mid 80s or second
half early in the second half of the 80s
I you know we had very few tests and I
sort of said to him ok mr. were doing
well I'll see you maybe in three months
time and I would like you to come back
with a what we call now a cd4 cell count
at that time we didn't call the cell
city for yet and he said why well I said
you know to follow progress somehow and
he said to me you know I don't expect
you to follow I expect you to anticipate
ok and so this is the sort of lessons
you you learned and I think by by
expressing their needs so so so freely
by learning about treatment options in
those days more rapidly than doctors
somehow i think the patients became
leaders themselves in the way that I
think we didn't know before aids and so
that's another another lesson it and the
new I think a totally new paradigm it
took them the world many years before it
recognized the extent of the hcp they
became the developing world although my
colleague and close friend
photo is valet see Lucy Nobel laureate
this year had shown in 1985 heterosexual
transmission of HIV in Cameroon and in
actually several other countries in in
central Africa but didn't didn't take
until you know the 90s and the late 90s
before the world somehow uh knowledged
and recognized the disaster of fades in
the developing world and it didn't take
it take it took until the late 90s and
the early 2000s really for the world to
actually begin to seriously act to
rectify the emerging inequities in the
response to AIDS between the North and
the South at that time so I'm now
jumping a few years end of the 90s and
early 2000s I I had the privilege of
being the director of the National
Agency for AIDS research in France
called the a and RS which is the large
and actually the second largest you know
research entity on unaids after the US
was smaller of course much smaller
budget inand but I was actually strongly
determined to to reorient the work of
that agency and and starting from 1998
1998 you may remember or some of you may
remember was the Acosta the African
conference on aids that took place in
abidjan cote d'ivoire and in that
conference Binaca snare the founder of
MSF you know said that the patients are
in the south and the drugs are in the
north I think a very powerful way of
talking about the inequities in this
world and President Xi hawk
called for the first time for treatment
of AIDS in the developing world
something no one would think you know to
consider in any other way than just an
impossible dream at that time 1998 so we
sort of reoriented the agency so that
actually up to a third or over a third
of its budget was directed towards
medical research clinical research but
also social science research on the AIDS
epidemic in developing countries and and
these were great days these were days
where some of the first trials where
took place the trial on on whether
bactrim is is prophylactic in in the
setting of a aids in the developing
world the first trials AZT trials to
prevent mother-to-child transmission of
the virus in in abidjan setting in 1999
the first cohort of patients on
treatment on antiretroviral treatment in
in Senegal Senegal was the first country
in Africa to start a national program on
AIDS then looking at the efficacy the
tolerance of the first fixed dose
combination of generic drugs try immune
to that was 2003 later um and as as we
were entering in the early 2000s you
know results from all these studies and
a number of of studies now the evidence
was was coming to actually help build
the advocacy for the demand for access
to treatment in in the global south
remember what I said about evidence as
as the fundamental
is for for advocacy and and and for
leadership you know in 2001 people had
and I actually had a slide on that they
had you know many many reasons to to say
that scaling up access to treatment for
AIDS in the developing world was just
impossible it was impossible because the
drugs people were saying are too
expensive in 2000 a first-line drug
regimen for AIDS cost ten thousand
dollars per patient per year the lowest
price we're now paying at the Global
Fund for a first-line regimen is ninety
two dollars per patient per year okay
people were saying we don't know whether
patients will will take the treatment
where they will be as we call it
adherent to treatment whether they will
tolerate the treatment where the
treatment will be effective in
resource-limited settings and all the
evidence accumulated in the early 2000s
that not only our patients adherent to
treatment in the developing world in the
course but actually they're even more
and they show better adherence that that
the courts in the north and there is now
ample evidence you know about the
effectiveness of the treatment even in
some of the poorest settings people are
say we're saying treatment is not
cost-effective there is now evidence
that aids treatment is actually one of
the most cost effective interventions we
have had in medicine much more cost
effective than treating myocardial
infarction when it comes to 22 lives
saved and and not speaking of preventing
mother-to-child transmission of HIV
which is a you know an intervention of
which the cost is around 15 US dollars
people were saying that if we hurry too
much in disseminating treatment in the
South treatment will not be taken
appropriately and we will generate
resistance and there will be a sort of
second wave you know epidemic of
resistant HIV and I heard actually I'm
sorry to say professors gallo and more
than yay you know claims such I think
unacceptable statements 2003 2004 and of
course that doesn't hold true actually
there is less resistance currently in
what we know from the courts in the
south than what we see in in the north
so these were extraordinary years of a
sort of hope about where we could be and
there there are a number of people you
know a number of leaders of people whom
I just like to mention that I think have
been my heroes in in those days and I
would like them to inspire you somehow
in this leadership discussion Christine
Cataldo she is a woman living with HIV
in Burkina Faso and she was one of the
first women to come up as and talk about
her being 0 positive and she actually
appeared on placards all over booking
fso on the roads together with with
President camp array danielle de faire
then yelled affair was actually the the
partner the lover of philosopher Michel
Foucault who died of aids in the early
1990s and he was the founder of one of
the of the sort of leading NGO against a
in my country called ed together with
with Danielle the fairway in the late
80s opened what something that I'm
actually proud of which is what I called
la cosa de sel de soie or the night
clinic these we're days where
discrimination was very high and it was
very difficult for a young man or a
young woman having a normal life working
to actually explain to her or his boss
that you know I need half a day to
actually go to the hospital because that
was immediately raised suspicions
somehow so we opened the clinic that was
running from 6 p.m. to midnight on
Wednesdays that clinic is now 16 years
old and it's still going on it was a
very interesting experience because on
the one hand that was bringing allowing
people to to be in a sort of anonymous
environment then they wouldn't have to
explain again to miss work or or explain
why they would have to miss work but at
the same time it was a unique clinic
because all people who were there sort
of sitting together waiting in the
evening and in the silence of the
evening in the hospital you can't
imagine how a silent a hospital is in
the night and how noisy it is in the day
they were realizing you know that all
they were all having this disease for
which we have no treatment and they
would see from time to time how one of
them would deteriorate and that would
you know act as a sort of mirror on on
them anyway daniele de faire Zackie
Achmat some of you may have heard of
Zaki who is the leader from tagged
treatment the treatment Action Coalition
in South Africa that is an extraordinary
movement
civil society movement false was bias in
Lucy whom I mentioned this year's Nobel
laureate a very humble extraordinary
basic scientist who was actually the
first person to see the virus to
identify the virus and so when I think
of these people you know I come to my
fourth lesson on leadership here and the
fourth lesson is that what all of these
leaders in science and in communities
have in common I think is that to
challenge acceptance of the status quo
they said that we do not we have not we
cannot just accept or keep accepting
things as they are always as they have
always been before because because that
we we know that treatment works we know
that we can do something we can just no
longer placidly accept that a person
living with AIDS in Africa you know
wouldn't would be condemned to die
whereas a person living with AIDS in the
u.s. in the US or in Europe work would
live challenge challenge acceptance of
the status quo now act up remember so to
summarize that sort of section of my
remarks that story came to me with or a
sort of thought of for for lessons the
first the importance of evidence as a
basis for advocacy and leadership the
second is the importance of humility and
of the limits of Medicine this means
accepting that rarely within one's own
field or discipline is one possessed
with all the answers and this is
particularly true and this came
particularly true with AIDS because it's
a disease with such complex social
dimensions that has so much
to teach us all third it's the
extraordinary leadership of patients and
of people with diseases in general as
you prepare for for leadership in global
health in actually formulating the
responses themselves and force is the
address I said the importance of
challenging acceptance of status quo